retour à paris où des dizaines de
personnes ont tenté de s'introduire il y
à quelques minutes dans le théâtre des
bouffes du nord à paris le chef de
l'état évalue l macron ne serait venu
assister à une représentation il y a un
peu plus de 20 minutes maintenant
selon des vidéos que vous voyez ici
qu'il y ait sur twitter des individus
ont tenté de pénétrer à l'intérieur du
théâtre ils ont été repoussés par les
forces de l'ordre les crs ont été
appelés en renfort selon ces vidéos ils
ont établi à présent un cordon de
sécurité autour de ce théâtre et
pourront parler nous sommes nous avec
notre reporter sur place j'en attends
douada par téléphone
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir jonathan vous êtes devant le
théâtre des bouffes du nord à paris
quelle est la situation actuellement
écoutes effectuées le temps est en train
de se pendre le commissaire de police
les commissaires des crs est en train de
faire les les premières sommations pour
demander aux manifestants de se
disperser
il chantait de personnes environ
rassemblées dans le cas pour les enfants
d derrière moi deux camps dvd slogans
aussi le chef de l'état ya quelques
minutes m et bien les forces de l'ordre
ont lancé effectivement une charge sont
étoffées musique et en permettant au
convoi du président la république
le site et de quitter la zone et donc le
plus de marquer vite et est donc est
parti de ce théâtre mais ces
manifestants n'ont qu'une manhattan
centaines d'angolais sont toujours ici
déterminé je vois défiler wang et de
l'oxydé des grévistes qui était présent
aujourd'hui devant lui
aujourd'hui à paris mais aussi des
certainement des manifestants aussi
facilement des grévistes mobilisés
contre cette réforme des retraites que
le gouvernement veut actuellement
certifiées donc pour l'instant j'en
attends on sait donc on peut confirmer
que le président emmanuel macron était
bien à l'intérieur de ce théâtre a
visiblement il n'a pas pu
terminez en tout cas cette
représentation puisqu'il a été évacuée
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de vous
dire
ces manifestants qui finalement ont
improvisé cette manifestation et c'est
une vidéo sur twitter qui a montrée
justement le président à l'intérieur de
ce théâtre qui a qui a fait un peu boule
de neige et qui a fait que ces
manifestants se sont rassemblés
c'est exact oui bah c'est le petit comme
ça que j'ai pu avoir l'information et me
rendre sur place et vous savez que les
autres sociaux les la formation va très
très vite et bien on est en plein
mouvement social de contestation de la
réforme des retraites
les gens sont vraiment extrêmement
motivés donc et centaines de personnes
se sont se sont retrouvés très
rapidement ici et au théâtre des bouffes
du nord pour essayer de faire entendre
leur mécontentement patault président de
la république différente en tant que
leurs revendications qui pour lire la
très grande majorité présents expliquent
ce soir c'est l'exigence du retrait du
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
oui on a vu cet après midi une autre
intrusion celle de quelques individus au
siège de la cfdt syndicat réformiste qui
a compromis est en tout cas avec le
gouvernement sur ce fameux âge pivot
c'est la colère l'acquis que vous sentez
qui montrent le fait que finalement
cette retraite passe sans action
possible puisque même la mobilisation
semble semble s'essouffler dans la rue
écoutez moi je n'ai pas vu les actions
de la cgt ce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui
c'est le blocage du musée du lourd est
ce que je vois c'est que les fermes sont
un peu lassé des cortèges
traditionnelles saucisses et merguez
frites de la fusée entre bastille et
nation ils voient bien que et bien des
manifestations malheureusement ne
portent pas leurs fruits
donc eh bien ils cherchent à faire des
actions qui change de l'ordinaire
ce matin il ya eu effectivement
apparemment la tentative d'intrusion à
l'atp il ya eu le blocage du musée du
loup par des employés du musée mais
aussi des professeurs on a vu aussi des
cheminots qui étaient là bas est là et
bien cette action spontanée qui était
donc pas prévu mais comme on dit c'était
l'occasion qui fait le larron ils ont
ils ont vu cette image shows les réseaux
sociaux et le président la république
leur semble tellement inaccessible
eh bien ils ont saisi cette opportunité
pour pour venir faire entendre leur
mécontentement à à quelques mètres
seulement du chef de l'état est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ce que vous
entendez autour de vous est ce que quels
sont les slogans que crient les
manifestant quelles sont les
revendications
bah écoutez je vais maintenant me
reproche à un petit peu la situation est
toujours et toujours ce côté là il s'est
sauvé il se sauver eux on veut retirer
la réforme chaque toile train de dire et
à l'aller les policiers et sont un peu
plus détendu l'aller la plupart des
manifestants se situe en fait sûr de
l'autre côté de la rue il ya un tas de
terre plein central
ils sont plutôt groupe est là une petite
centaine de manifestants toujours de
l'ambiance est pas tellement à leur
compte en plutôt bonne enfant si l'on
investir là et là ils nous disent puis
stand mâcon mettront tôt pour commenter
mais salutaire dans la décapiter c'est
l'ambiance est bon enfant mais il ya
quand même quelques slogans les journaux
radicaux est-ce que vous avez eue
jonathan le président de la république
sortir de ce de ce théâtre
alors moi au moment où je suis arrivé
j'ai vu les camions de féret petit kit
éloigné au loin on a essayé avec un
confrère de les rattraper mais
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu mais
quand je suis arrivé exactement devant
le théâtre j'ai pu m'entretenir avec un
avec un autre confrère qui lui avait vu
tout les faits mais donc effectivement
il a lu le président la république qui
fédère des français qui désespère
d'avoir une réponse de la part des
manuels macron qui s'est mis plutôt en
retrait sans mauvais jeu de mots en de
ce dossier des retraites qui n'a qui
l'aide qu'il a donné à son premier
ministre la colère est palpable
oui moi effectivement tout plutôt de
premier ministre la ja conducteur de
métro qui a klaxonné les manifestants et
les manifestants qu ont correspondu par
des applaudissements effectivement c'est
le hilo philippe qui a d'abord porté ce
projet de réforme des retraites mais je
crois que depuis et notamment le début
du mouvement des défilés zone en avant
de visiter et tous les mouvements qui
ont suivi depuis
c'est surtout le chef de l'état qui se
cristallise la la colère populaire et
ses contacts sont mobilisés ce soit même
s'ils ne sont pas très nombreux c'est
quand même significatif de quelque chose
à voir comme ça ils centaines de
personnes 400 peur qu'ils se mobilisent
deux au dernier moment à je te passer de
rien il est 22h30 vous sortez de chez
vous pour aller montrer votre colère à
22h30 jette après la publication d'une
d'une vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux ça
montre quand même pied il se passe
quelque chose en fait ouais un climat un
climat très ton dur on le voit et ses
adieux à tirer j'imagine aussi autour de
nombreux badauds j'en attends non
excusez-moi je changerai pas ma porte je
disais ça a dû attirer aussi beaucoup de
curieux dans le quartier plutôt animée
oui bah écoutez il est quand même assez
tard et si donc il ya quelques passants
qui rentrent chez eux mais globalement
les personnes qui sont rassemblés ici
sont avant tout des des manifestants des
automobilistes six reprises dans les
bouchons que christ de rassemblement à
partir
alors il ya la colère de ce gouvernement
qui n'entend pas finalement et dont on
sait que la négociation avec les
syndicats a été très compliqué pour
certains syndicats non réformiste qui
ont dit que la négociation n'en était
pas une que c'était une consultation et
que les finalement les grandes mesures
de cette réforme était écrite à l'avancé
la marge de négociation reste est assez
un film c'est la colère aussi des
usagers peut-être à paris qui n'en
peuvent plus d'un côté de ces de ces
blocages mais qui soutiennent toujours
selon les sondages majoritairement ce
mouvement social contre la réforme des
retraites
écoutez là je crois que la population
qu'il était présente ici devant le
devant le théâtre et j'ai surtout des
manifestants des grévistes pour beaucoup
de jeunes personnes très certainement
des étudiants au niveau des usagers je
sais pas apparemment il ya une personne
qui viennent me dire qu'ils ne le
personnes avaient été interpellées mais
mais j'ai pas vu la scène donc voilà
c'est simple statu quo l'a été ce soir
devant le devant le théâtre des bouffes
du nord explique nous décrire peut-être
le dispositif policier qui est qui est
mis en place autour de ce théâtre il ya
des crs qui ont été appelés en renfort
quelle est l'attitude de ces forces de
police bah écoute et l'état sont casqués
boucliers à la main qu'ils voulaient ils
sont disposés en colonne de 2,4 ou
spacca gens disposés devant le théâtre
ils sont environ une quarantaine je
dirais ça fait devant le théâtre me qui
truquent les toutes les ruelles de temps
qu'il y avait des policiers qui se sont
déployés dd on l'envoie entend arriver
des gyrophares et et des camions de
police qui cette fois ci qui semble-t-il
mmmm des renforts mais pour tomber pas
découragé les manifestants qui reste là
toujours des théories mère est là il le
paie le titre tout en python tente grève
générale oui ça rappelle aussi un autre
épisode un jaune est ton celui d'aider
gilet jaune au début de ce mouvement
lorsque la plupart des manifestants
voulaient marcher vers l'elysée pour se
faire entendre du président de la
république le président qui lui avait
s'était réfugié à la long terme
oui mais effectivement il ya eu
plusieurs faits main ou le président de
la république était hué sur son patin ou
autre et on parlait des gilet jaune y en
a j'en vois quelques-uns te sort dans la
foule c'est sûr que ce mouvement de
contestation sociale a un petit peu rien
inventé la contestation sociale en leur
en france on parlait tout à l'heure de
des manifestations traditionnelles qui
ne portaient pas leurs fruits
eh bien je pense que effectivement ce
mouvement dg les jeux dans la pulsé de
nouvelles formes aussi de de
contestation telle qu'on voit encore ce
soir à paris et jonathan j'imagine que à
l'intérieur du théâtre finalement le
lait la vie a repris son cours la
représentation se tient néanmoins ce
soir vous pensez vous avez des
renseignements là dessus malheureusement
je ne peux vous donner aucune
information n'a vraiment ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que mise à part le
président la république
qui est partie d'escorté donc deux
policiers et c est peut-être donc
laissons son entourage le confrère m'a
parlé de son maître se tromper en
communication qui était présent avec lui
et bien mise à part toi y'a aucun aucun
badauds aucun spectateurs du théâtre
pendant le semblait être sortie pour le
moment
est-ce que vous pouvez nous vous nous
refaire un petit polo le récapitulatif
de cette intrusion ce soir aux alentours
de 21h45 le président de la république a
été aperçue en train d'entrer dans ce
théâtre des bouffes du nord
hélas les manifestants ont fait des
appels sur les réseaux sociaux
et bah oui donc c'est parti d'une vidéo
qui est qui a tourné sur les réseaux
sociaux mettant en scène le plus beau
marais public dans cette de ce qu'est
être des boucs tu n'en est bien sûr les
réseaux militants très vite et caetera
et bien c'était donné tu connais le
peintre allemand de devenir et petit
espoir être non le aucun des bouffes du
nord et donc plusieurs plusieurs
dizaines de cartons dahir n ya toujours
moyen des manifestants tu te disais
quelques minutes il ya un manifestant ou
une manifestante qui avaient été
interpellées et là c'est des
manifestants sans me demander sa
libération
et donc les manifestants entraînant
veille à la chaussée
et qu'on fasse nos forces de l'ordre qui
tentent en dans leur pseudo
non moi aucune animosité plus que
l'ambiance est pour l'instant cordiale
de ce que mon mentor je réponds c'est
que des personnes sont venues avec des
négateurs en tout cas oui bah vous savez
que malheureusement aucun heureusement
salon pas venu mais il ya eu tellement
de m tellement de manifestations ces
dernières semaines ce dernier il ya un
politique en train de repousser une
manifestante
et donc il ya une petite petite montée
de tension mais là les sterett par la
voir là la situation qui montre
oui apparaît du mois du port ouais oui
apparemment il doit être annoncée aux as
et à ces personnes que la personne
attendu était déjà parti sous-entendu le
président de la république est déjà
parti éparpillés vous un peu le message
qui est donné ce soir
oui effectivement moi c'est les
déductions données fait parce que tant
un cocher arrivés sur place de vue tout
un convoi bien quitter le boulevard de
la chapelle et dès que je suis arrivé
sur place j'ai vu un contrat qui m'a qui
m'a confirmé l'information sont arrêtés
le le président de la république étaient
partis mais bon je suppose que les
manifestants le savent aussi
mais maintenant qu'ils sont là je pense
qu'ils veulent quand même marquer le
coup et des pas dire qu'ils sont
descendus dans la rue pour rien que ce
soit est vrai et faire entendre leurs
revendications sont notamment l'abandon
de la réforme des retraites n'est pas le
gouvernement
merci beaucoup jonathan madame merci
d'avoir fait le point pour rt france en
direct jeudi en direct des bouts du nord
à paris sur cette intrusion surprise de
de certaines personnes au théâtre des
bouffes du nord ce soir à 21h45 à peu
près le président de la république qui
était donc venu assister à une
représentation
non il a été aperçu
une image qui a été relayé sur les
réseaux sociaux et des manifestants qui
ont décidé qu'ils ont essayé en tout cas
de rentrer à l'intérieur de ce théâtre
pour faire entendre leur mécontentement
vis-à-vis apparemment de cette réforme
des retraites qui suit son cours